well good morning everyone good morning
I think we're just about ready to start
so
uh can I welcome you to this meeting of
mids suffet District Council cabinet I'm
councelor Andy melon leader of mids
suffet District Council and I'll be
chairing this
meeting just to First remind you of some
domestic arrangements please ensure that
your microphones are turned off when not
in use uh do not interrupt other
speakers and please switch off or turn
to silent any mobile phones
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs and meet on the iish
Town Football Club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you told it
is safe to do so and finally we will be
using EV voting for this meeting on the
modern. goov app so please could cabinet
members make sure they are logged in and
ready to use the
app i' like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast is
being broadcast live to the internet and
will be capable of repeated viewing the
whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to consented to being filmed and
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes but the council
members of the public and the Press May
record film photograph or broadcast the
meeting when the public and press are
not lawfully
excluded uh I see we've got quite a
number of officers here today welcome
all I'm not going to go around and
welcome you individually but thanks for
coming in today and can I move to the
agenda please item one apologies for
absence thank you chair we have received
apologies from councelor Teresa Davis
and we also have Karen Wat L the uh
inter corporate manager for finance
commissioning of procurement joining the
meeting
virtually thank you very much item two
to receive Declarations of pecuniary
other registrable or non-reg interests
by
members are there any to
declare no okay we can move on to item
three this is paper MCA stroke 23 Stoke
25 to confirm the minutes of the last
cabinet meeting which was held on the
5th of December
2023 are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the
minutes if not can I have a proposer
please councelor eburn and a
seconder councelor
Stringer uh the governance officer will
now conduct the vote thank you chair
that vote is in progress
now
thank you members that's five votes for
that's
unanimous thank you very
much item four is to receive
notifications of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme un
receed received item five questions by
counselors none received item six
matters referred by the overview and
scrutiny or joint audit and standards
committees there are no matters referred
chair thanks and in item seven is the
forthcoming decisions list which I'm
sure we've all had a look at are there
any comments on that list of forthcoming
decisions none okay thank you very much
we will move
on to to item eight and this is paper
MCA stroke 23 stroke 36 which is the
mids suffk
plan um and as the leader of the council
I will now
introduce the mids suffer
plan the document that we are putting
forward today is the culmination of
several months work by officers and
administration counselors and I'm very
grateful to uh to Joe Hobbs and her team
for bringing this forward in a very very
timely manner
the title set out the overarching aim of
the plan for our district helping to
create thriving and resilient
communities in mid
saug and we use the word helping
advisedly because these aims are not
something that this Council can achieve
alone uh we need to engage and involve
individuals households businesses
communities and all the partner
organizations that we work with if we
are to achieve
anything
the refreshing of the council's
corporate plan commenced with the
elections last May when a new green
majority Administration was
elected and we have committed to being
an open inclusive and listening Council
leadership and I believe we have
followed those principles in our first
few months and in the production of this
plan our initial draft plan was drawn up
last Autumn and presented at cabinet and
we then had a period of consultation
which took most of October and the first
half of
November uh the consultation had a
number of ways that people's views were
sought there was a questionnaire
available online and also in hard copy
there was engagement on social media
there were various meetings where the
views of hard-to-reach sectors of the
community were
canvased um I attended a couple of
meetings with the Chamber of Commerce
and local businesses where we received
feedback from them and also we had the
town and Parish uh Forum where we had a
consultant Le session drawing out the
views of community
leaders all this feedback was then taken
into consideration when refining the
draft plan into its final form so I'm
happy to present the plan today um this
plan will feed into the delivery plans
which will give the Practical detail of
how we impact the district over the next
few years um but I'm hoping that cabinet
will approve this plan today and then
we'll take it forward to council later
in the month um and I'm hoping that we
will get uh approval from all counselors
um in terms of what we've been putting
forward so I'm happy to propose the
uh the adoption of this plan uh could I
have a second
please councelor winch thank you very
much now do I have any questions from uh
cabinet
members any questions from other members
present councelor whad thank you chair
yes I I personally welcome a reduction
in the number of priorities
simplification and especially dropping
the Psychedelic wheel graphic in terms
of our approach set out on page
24 is this list set out as a hierarchy
of objectives will environmental
sustainability s to save the planet and
social justice conations always Trump
the provision of high quality services
and financial responsibility with public
money when they conflict or do cabinet
agree with me that high quality services
and financial responsibility should be
the two key drivers for this district
council with its modest place in The
Wider
world thank you for that question I
think
um to attempt to answer that clearly
these are um a number of cons
considerations that we need to balance
um I think we've made it clear uh and
the plan makes it clear that uh uh
environmental sustainability and social
justice are kind of key themes for us uh
and will inform all that we do
um I think when the argument is made
that
uh that those things need to be in
balance with um Economic Development or
other
considerations my my answer to that is
that um the economy has to live within
the ecology if we if we don't have a
sustainable environment nothing else
will Thrive um so I think there's always
going to be a balance between these
these um I wouldn't say them competing
uh aims and objectives but I think we
absolutely want to deliver the council
services to a high standard and we
believe that can be done um at the same
same time while uh having environmental
and social justice at the heart of what
we
do thank you very very considerate
response thank
you okay so I'll now open the item Up
For Debate does anyone else uh want to
make a contribution to the debate
councelor winch yeah I'd just like to
say Well done to everyone for getting to
this Point there's been a lot of work
and I think some people would look at it
and say oh we've only ended up with a
few pages here uh but it's often much
harder to use less words than more words
and I think this does give a very good
uh view as to what we're all about and I
think it forms a really good basis to
flesh out more detail in in the coming
years thank you kle
eburn um thank you chair i' I'd agree
with my my colleague that I think you
know doing a short plan is much more
difficult than doing a long one less
words rather than than more and um I
would also like to thank all um officers
and colleagues for their work in getting
this um to this stage but as an
Administration um and as a as a green
majority I think it's really important
that we say to everybody that we're
putting environmental and social
responsibilities at the heart of
everything that we do and and um that is
extremely important and I think with
regards to the work that the council
does which comes across in this document
here it's it's not about um residents or
businesses or whoever being done to it's
about working with and we really need to
kind of work with all Partners work with
all citizens to um ensure that we're
making um mids the thriving place that
we that we all love so I would be very
pleased to um support this thank you
chair thank you counc Le councelor
Stringer sorry chair wrong microphone um
yeah just like to Holy endorse uh this
council's plan uh first of all thank you
to the team and the staff uh and
everyone that engaged with this it's
always very difficult to get public and
stakeholders to engage with often uh
certainly if you badget a corporate plan
it it appears on the to be incredbly dry
uh uh and it's difficult to engage with
I I'm sort of impressed with the amount
of people that did engage in the end and
and thanks to everyone for that um I
think it's it's really good a good way
of as it were of setting out a store uh
and and actually losing the word
corporate from the corporate plan I
think is the single best thing we've
done because we are not a corporation we
are a council and we are here to serve
the the needs of our residents and
communities uh and I think think and I
certainly think that the numbering of
all this is is is no indication of
hierarchy it but it is an expression of
how all of these themes are Interlink
you probably can have a thriving
Community if you don't have open and
honest leadership but you'll make that
incredibly hard to do if you don't have
open and honest leadership so I think
for me all of the numbers 1 to8 are
interl and intertwined and they all rely
on each other and I think it's this sets
out almost a blueprint for what the
public and our residents and businesses
should expect from this Council but it's
also I think a set of values that we
should challenge each other on as well
uh so I say I wholly endorse the plan
and thank everyone involved with getting
it this far thank you
chair thank you very much any other
comments okay so um I'll just read the
recommendations and then we'll move to
the vote so recommendation 3.1 to
consider the feedback from engagement
and endorse the final mids plan setting
out the vision and strategic priorities
for mids District Council for 2023 to
2031 as set out in appendix a and we can
now move to the
vote thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
thank you members that's five votes for
that's unanimous chair thank you very
much that is
carried uh thank you again to the
officers for your input on that item
nine is uh paper MCA stroke 23 Stoke 37
this is the empty homes and second homes
policy um we've got um Emma andoa and
Deborah Fenton here to support uh on
this item and I'll now invite the
cabinet member for housing and property
councel winch to introduce the report if
you see councelor winch wandering about
it's not because he's lost interest it's
because he's protecting his his back and
his
uh yeah I'm not a great fan of standing
up at Council meetings but in this case
I'm going to um do that so
we've got about um 680 empty homes in
mids suffk and about half of those have
been empty for a year or more um and
empty homes are a waste of resources and
generally are have a negative impact on
communities and our primary focus with
empty homes is to work proactively with
landlords to try and bring the homes
back into use we've got two main
services for this houses for homes which
offers advice guidance and practical
things like loans to get the properties
in a lettable state um and Central
suffix lettings which is like a Gateway
between a landlord and a tenant and the
idea is to give a landlord reassurance
that they can guarantee their their
income so uh that's the primary focus
what what the empty homes premium does
is give another aspect to our Armory to
try and get these homes back into use so
the proposal on the table is that um if
a home's been empty for a year or more
you p double council tax if it's been
empty for five years or more you pay
quad uh triple council tax and if it's
been empty for 10 years or more you pay
quadruple council tax uh there are
exceptions to this uh things like is the
property under probate is there a major
construction going on is somebody in the
military I don't know if the full list
of exceptions has been published yet but
the government I think are about
it um and this this change would come
come into force from April the 1st this
year um the second homes is slightly
different it doesn't come into Force for
a it wouldn't come into Force for a year
and the objective of doing the second
homes is twofold one is if you don't do
it it's a bit of a tax loophole because
you could just put some furniture in an
empty home and say it was a second home
uh and the other reason is I think it's
reasonable if somebody's lucky enough to
have a second home that they make an
extra contribution to the
community so uh in terms of total
council tax we're talking in the region
of half a million to 600,000 so for mids
suff that means somewhere between 50 and
60k um I think this is a common sense
measure because um we need to get empty
properties back into circulation if we
possibly can and if we can't then those
people are sitting on properties will
make a will make a contribution to the
community um we're not out on a limb
here I believe that babra I switch and
East suffer are going down the same rout
so I would strongly recommend that we
vote for
this thank you councilor winch can I
have a proposer and a seconder for
that Richard you're happy to propose
councelor winch and council eburn is
going to
Second any questions from cabinet
members on this
paper councelor
Weller thank you chair um it's a
question for um councilor winch are we
are we sufficiently resourced to be able
to place
this thank you chair um yeah in terms of
the plan we intend to write to those
that will be impacted U during February
to advise of the change and invite
evidence as to perhaps where they fall
within the exceptions um from a resource
perspective we're fine to cover that um
because we deal with amendments on a
daily basis so we haven't got concerned
all we are waiting is counc which just
said is for the government's list of
exceptions they still to be
confirmed Council aurn
um thank you chair um my question was
actually just following on um from that
is that the list of government um
exceptions do we have any idea so I'm
looking at Andrew Wilcock in this of of
when we might know what they are and I'm
presumably if these ones have been
included within previous consultation
they're not likely to to change but um
we would obviously need to have these
before we actually implement this now we
certain of that as it
were thank you chair uh originally they
were due out before Christmas but um we
got feedback due to a changeing minister
it's been delayed to the early part of
this year so I would hope you know in
the next s month really but you're right
we do need them before the end of
February I think we've got every Council
in the country looking at this so if
they don't produce them I think it'll be
a
problem so we're confident they'll be
available before the the measure comes
in we hope so I mean you can never be
confident with government but yes we we
should have that information but again
the policy has written that we've uh got
discretion written into the policies if
they're not there and we find out
circumstances we feel should be accepted
we've written the policy so we can
include
those thank you very much any other
questions from cabinet
members uh any questions from other
members councilor whad thank you chair
yes sir um I've got a list of questions
mainly addressed to the second H aspect
because I given this a lot of thought
when it came up this time last year so
could I ask the chair that cabinet
either at worst simply Human by
listening to the questions or at best
give some serious consideration to the
points I'm raising when it comes to
debate right um 319 of the second homes
58% fall into Bands A and C a to c which
are fairly modest homes but might still
have a value of say 180 to 300,000 many
may have been acquired or inherited for
fraction of the current value and then
selling these second homes would now
crystallize significant capital gains
tax liability for their owners which
only crystallizes on the sale I'm asking
our cabinet happy to catch these owners
into a vice likee grip where on the one
hand they must either pay probably tens
of thousands of pounds in capital gains
tax on disposal or by retaining the
property pay thousands of pounds of
additional second home tax premiums it
seems to me that these people are
between a rock and a hard place that's
my first
question second question Rising on the
second homes is in this new era of work
from home or even work from anywhere how
will second homes be defined so a couple
traveling out to mids second home on a
Thursday evening and not leaving till
Monday evening will stay four nights out
of seven working part from home and uh
which of these homes then really is the
second home it seems to me it's not an
easy definition there a single
individual owning two homes will pay 75%
council tax on their main home where
they use the majority of the services
and 200% on their more occasional second
home does that feel right to Cabinet I
wonder how many of these 542 second
homes have a very low efficiency rating
might be better used to second summer
homes rather than being all year round
fossil fuel energy traps
um the uh and does cabinet share my
concern this tax can be more EAS less
easily avoided by married couples in
contrast to couples who just lived
together the latter can declare they
have decided to live separately but
still intertwined lives and each will
just pay 75% single person council tax
rather than 100 plus 200 but a married
couple in contrast would need to create
a trial separation to avoid these penal
taxes and in all these cases mared are
married will Council officers be
employed to investigate the claims or
will the council instead rely on some
sort of East Germany communist style
spying by their neighbors to decide on
the situation or indeed both I just feel
with just 1% of second homes falling
into the category um it's not like we've
got a problem such as Lake District
cells North nor or suff Coast I just
feel the second Home Premium policy
raises moral and ethical questions I I
personally feel it's an obnoxious and
pentious tax based on the politics of
Envy which will raise little extra money
for this particular District
Council okay thank you for those points
um and I hope we we can address them in
in debate um so the first one was about
uh capital gains tax versus council tax
in terms of people owning and have
possibly having to dispose of second
homes um um there's a question about
whether um homes if they are of um you
know poor insulation would just be
suitable as summer homes sort of Chalet
rather than sort of uh for year round
habitation uh question about people
paying the single pre the single
supplement so 75% versus
200% um and there was a fourth point
there sorry I
yes so how do we how do we actually sort
of capture whether is genuinely a second
home uh or whether people are living
separately and the implications of
that try to avoid this by various
methods you know will we employ officers
to investigate this or will we relying
on neighbors and questioning them as the
sort of spying on your neighbor type
approach yeah yeah I think the point is
you know do are we going to be sort of
having a sort of starzy operation to try
and make sure we know what's happening
and what the arrangements are um for
people who are trying to avoid this does
do anyone want to sort respond to those
points I'm I'm going to need to take
advice on the detailed points about
definition of second homes and things
but just on on the general principle
here we we need the second homes premium
one to stop a loophole in the empty
homes otherwise you can just part
furnish them and save them you can it's
so easy to get around that tax
all taxes that you introduce have a risk
that somebody will find a way of getting
round but in terms of the principle of
somebody paying extra council tax to the
community because they they've got a
second home I'm personally Rock Solid on
that as a principal uh it isn't
scientific but because I knew we were
doing this I actually talked to a few
people in our my ward and they all said
the same thing it seems reasonable that
if you're in a lucky position to have a
second home that you should contribute
more to the community uh so I think
we're pretty Rock Solid on that I accept
that there's always in when you go down
to the bottom level of detail some
difficulties in collecting certain taxes
but I know that Andrew will cover this
where you know we do get areas where
that's very difficult we have to make a
sensible judgment but in principle I
think we're we're definitely in the
right place did did you want to comment
and yeah thank you chair so um although
we're using the term second homes the
government called them periodically
occupied properties so this is a
property that is furnished and isn't
somebody's sole or main residence so for
council tax we have to for everybody we
build we have to identify whether it is
their so or my own residence which is
what we would do with a second home or
if potentially a couple indicate that
one lives in one property and one lives
in another property we have to to ask
the relevant questions to ID identify
where their main residence is um you
might have examples where somebody has
moved into the area
because it's closer to where they work
but actually their family home is
elsewhere and arguably their family home
would be their main residence their
second home would be a property they've
moved into but again within the um
potential Exceptions there are issue
exceptions around job related dwelling
so you know we have to ask ask the
questions we ask the questions now to
identify where somebody's main residence
is um you know for a family arguably
it's the family
property we have covered some of those
questions with the single person
discount as you know we do review those
annually and we use external data to to
look at um you know the validity of
people receiving a single person
discount so again we already have the
processes in place to look at where
there's potentially
avoidance whether that's answer your
questions Council
what okay thank you for that
clarification um if there's no further
questions then we'll move into debate on
this item um who would like to um make a
contribution to the debate councilor
Stringer thank you um yeah I I think
this is a uh it seems a bold move but
actually it's a pretty Common Sense move
um if you've got uh properties that sit
there and are perceived by a community
to be idle it it really does uh pull on
uh Community tensions often uh and I
think moving towards this is is little
to do with the Pol I wasn't quite sure
if the politics of Envy were were this
second homes policy or or the council
tax regime itself because the council
tax regime identifies a person and a
property and you always get into
difficulty with that I think I mean I
personally the the Co council tax regime
I'd rather we just tax the property uh
irrespective of of who's in it and then
you know where you are uh but I think if
we do have these these homes that are uh
longstanding empty that's such a waste
that's a waste of a of a badly needed
home it's also a waste of of injecting
stuff into local communities and buying
from local services and injecting money
into the local economy uh and I think if
this Administration says that we're
going to be sharp on that that uh then
we should be but equally we need to make
sure that we're also sharp on ourselves
so if we if we hold the public to a high
Target for making sure homes are are
used we need to set our own standards
for our own homes to make sure they come
into use as quickly as possible as well
so that we also get people housed and
red so yes it it looks a bold move uh I
have to say I I disagree with counselor
Whitehead on many of the points uh but
gladly debate with him outside of this
this chamber on some of those finer
points if you want I personally don't
think it's the politics of MB it's the
politics of utility frankly so I will be
voting for this thank
you thank you very much councelor eurn
um thank you chair I'll certainly be
supporting um this recommendation um on
the empty homes um I think it's a shame
that we didn't um increase these um
options for extra additional council tax
when we had the opportunity um 5 years
ago um and I'm very pleased that we we
as a a new Administration are able to do
it now and also I'm very confident in
the teams that we've got the in the the
team in housing with regards to kind of
helping get those empty homes back into
use and with programs for um as has been
mentioned by my my colleague programs
for um landlords to help them um to
actually um get those homes um rented
out so I'm really pleased to see that
and as well as the the team um at the um
council tax collection end as it were so
that um is very helpful and I'm really
pleased to see that and with regards to
the the second homes um I think that you
know if if one is you
know these homes also should be in use
if if second home owners have got an
issue with their home and and don't wish
to be you know using as a second home
again we can we can help them them also
um provide kind of opportunities to get
that rented out so I think you know the
councils across the country are looking
at this and I think is a a very positive
um story for our residents um of of mids
suffix I'll definitely be supporting it
thank
you any further contributions to
debate okay thank you so I think
uh we are mov moving forward with this
alongside other councils across the
region and across the country um appears
to me that if someone is fortunate
enough to have a second
home uh and they choose to leave it
empty we're not compelling them to use
it but we are asking them to contribute
further to the the community uh and this
seems to be a fair and reasonable thing
to me so um I think we can now U I'll
just read the recommendations and then
we'll move forward to the votes so
recommendation
3.1 that Council approved the empty
homes and second homes premiums policy
for 2425 attached in appendix
a 3.2 the council delegate authority to
the director of housing in consultation
with the cabinet member for housing and
property to make technical amendments to
the policy to ensure it meets the
criteria set by government and the
council and I will now ask the
governance officer to conduct the
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now in programed
thank you members that's five votes for
that's unanimous
chair thank you very much that is
passed so we now move on to item 10 this
is paper
MCA stroke 23 stroke 38 the greenhouse
gas report for 2022 stroke 23 and we
have a couple of officers um helping
with this one so Sarah wding who's our
climate change manager and we have Mano
choan our climate change consultant here
thanks for coming in today um and I'm
going to ask the cabinet member for
environment culture and well-being to
introduce the report councelor Weller
thank you chair um cabinet's invited to
note this report which summarizes
council's efforts to reduce its
emissions in the fiscal year ending
march 2023 this shows a reduction of
around a, tons less than the previous
reporting previous reporting period so
this is good news where figures show
slightly higher than expected reductions
this can be attributed to the movement
of functions between scopes for example
all Leisure centers uh emissions and now
accounted for under the council's direct
responsibility so this is transferred
from scope three to scope two in the
report and our Grounds Maintenance
function was brought back inhouse so
that transfers from scope three to scope
one in the report the conversion of our
waste and public realm Fleet to
hydrogenated uh vegetable oil uh has had
a notable impact on reducing carbon
emissions but Leisure centers remain our
biggest emitters however we've put
measures in place to mitigate this issue
and we're awaiting the outcome of a
sport England funding bid which is due
at the end of this month to improve
these further looking forward it's
anticipated that the
23204 greenhouse gas report is unlikely
to show a significant reduction because
there' been no major interventions this
year however we may see an improvement
in terms of savings from solar car ports
that's realizing the lag effect of the
data capture in this
area it's of note that our uh emissions
in Leisure centers have dropped by 11.9%
since the last reporting period and
that's been as a result of roof mounted
solar uh photov volcanic panels the
introduction of low carbon heat pump
technology at the BS Hall in Stow market
and the replacement of Life expired
boilers with energy efficient boiler
plant and modern Control Systems we now
additionally benefit from a fully
recruited climate change team so we've
um so they've been able to commence work
to review the range of council assets
identify
where we can make greenhouse gas savings
as well as Financial savings this
enables audit and robust analysis of the
effectiveness of for example our solar
photovoltaic
panels our 2223 performance is currently
2.8% from where it needs to be we'll
need to see reductions on average of
539 tons of carbon each year to reach
Net Zero by 2030 so it's a big
ask the next round of public sector
decarbonization funding uh which is
phase four opens later this year and
we're already looking at what assets we
can potentially bid for so in conclusion
and after thanking officers and partners
for their time and diligence in
producing the technical report and the
accompanying paper I'd like to propose
that we vote to note the report
thanks thank you do we have a second
councelor
eburn um so
do we have questions from cabinet
members on this report and the
paper councelor winch this is probably a
question I shouldn't ask but are are we
going to hit the target or not what is
your
view thank you Richard for that one um
so um it's it's it's a it's a really
tough call um the chances are we might
get get very very close to it I think is
the answer though I'm I might ask uh
learning colleagues on the benches
further away to give us to give us their
professional opinion on that as well uh
I I'll invite them to come in
now so shall I ask um who's going to
take this Sarah Wilding are you going to
answer thank
you um yeah you know we
will we don't want to change it we don't
want to uh roll back on it as other
councils have um because then you're
obviously going to be looking at will we
achieve that date so we'll we'll try our
very
best can't do any more than that thank
you very much any further questions from
cabinet
members
council whad do you have any
questions okay so we can open this item
Up For
Debate anyone like to contribute to the
debate councelor
eurn um thank you very much CH chair um
I'll um obviously this report is for
noting but I think that um it's going to
be hard work um getting um greenhouse
gas emissions down further and I think
the past couple of years we've um lwh
hanging fruit as as it were has been
been got and so the easy options have
been done um and now for for us there'll
be the harder um options to to consider
and and take forward but I've got no
doubt that we will rise to that
challenge and I think the team here will
be um you know working hard to to do
that as well as us um in the
administration so I'm hopeful that we
will get there and I think also in the
process of doing so um we will be able
to show new initiatives um including um
being able to um save financially and
actually show our communities and take
our communities with us um on that
Journey thank
you Council
Stringer yeah uh appreciate uh the work
that's gone into the report and thank
you for that uh and also appreciate its
cander and honesty which is what what we
want with this and also the recognition
that you know the quick wins we're we're
probably getting past those and and
there's going to be harder challenges in
the future uh one of the other
challenges that we're going to face and
we we need to be honest about that is is
is decisions that we get from on high
from central government uh if we get
central government choose a betamax
option for a particular technology and
fund that that then doesn't deliver uh
it's going to make it all the harder for
us to fulfill our own Ambitions here but
I think with some of the work we're also
doing in attempting to skill up uh some
of those newer Enterprises in in the
green economy in mids it should put us
in a a good state with Partners to
actually make sure that we can not only
deliver for us but also make it easier
for others to decarbonize and meet those
targets as well but I'll be voting to
approve that we note this report thank
you thank you very much anyone
else
okay well I'll just make a few comments
from the chair then I think the perhaps
the key um graphic in this uh in this
report is the graph graph nine on page
62 which shows the target of um
emissions uh a straight line down to
Zero by
2030 as a green line and then the
actual what has been achieved so far as
a blue line um
and the good thing I suppose we can
argue is that um we've made progress uh
in in this reporting period and we are
now back closer to where we need to be
than we were a year ago um and um this
is good and we should be really pleased
about that but as others have said we do
have a long way to go and once you've
picked the low hanging fruit it becomes
progressively more difficult to deal
with carbon emissions
um at at the lower level um and it may
be possibly that at the end we will have
to do some offsetting in order to reach
um zero but obviously uh our our
commitment that we've made uh and
particularly in joining the organization
UK 100 is that we will aim to absolutely
minimize offsetting and do most that we
can do by reducing emissions
directly however this is only part of of
the picture uh this if we were to take
the whole District's
emissions uh I think the council is
responsible for something like two or 3%
of of the of the district's entire
emissions um these are the bits that we
have power
over we have influence over perhaps 30
or 40% and that's the the big prize the
areas where we need to um we need to
challenge our residents and our
communities to reduce their emissions
and obviously we are making some
progress on that we have the um cozy
homes uh insulation scheme which will be
which is providing uh free or subsidized
insulation to homes across the district
and that program is rolling out now and
that hopefully will have an impact but
as Council Stringer said we are so
dependent on what central government
decides to do uh and we really need the
leadership from central government in
order to um to see see the kind of big
changes that are
required um to reduce the districts and
the country's emissions in total but I'm
certainly going to be voting for this
report voting to note it and we look
forward to further iterations of it and
we hope to see further progress and
we're certainly committed to drawing
down this council's emissions over the
next few
years so I'll just read the
recommendation 3.1 that the contents of
the greenhouse gas emissions report 2022
23 at appendix a to the report be noted
and I'll ask the governance officer to
conduct the
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now in
progress
thank you members that's five votes for
chair that's
unanimous thank you so that report is
noted and thank you to the officers for
your work on
that so we move on to item 11 this is
paper MCA stroke 23 Stoke 39 the fees
and charges for
2024 and 2025 and we've got various uh
officers
here to support this item markk M the
director of operations Tracy Howard the
corporate manager for public protection
Sean couter the senior Finance business
partner for revenue and Jack Burton
Finance business partner welcome all and
I will now ask the cabinet member for
finance and resources to introduce the
report councelor
eburn um thank thank you very much chair
um before I introduce the report um can
I just please point out some minor
Corrections to the report um the tables
on page 69 onwards should show um year
2324 versus
2425 um so there's a sort of copy and
paste typo there as it were and
additionally um within the tables there
are five um changes um so if I can just
take you through each one on page um 70
Zoo license renewal um we don't have any
zoos in our district so that should say
um volume per year um zero um further
down that page uh dog breeders um
renewal we've got 15 of those and so the
figure in the budget income growth
should say
540 um further down that page hiring out
horses renewal um there's two of those
so in the um budget income growth that
should say
um76
on the following page home borders
renewal the we've got 14 of those so
that figure in the budget income growth
should be
£350 and finally um on page 73 the um
provision of boarding cats or dogs 31
plus the renewal we've got three of
those so that figure should say um 51
now that's a total of
[Music]
1,07 um there which I p is a small
amount but it's very important that this
um report should be um
correct so with regards to fees and
charges they're set annually and this
report um details them for the
forthcoming Financial year
2425 and while the council cannot charge
for some statutary services and national
government sets others discretionary
charges such as vehicle licensing Lin
empting and pavement licensing can be
set locally by
us in assessing the level of fees and
charges for the new Financial year we
take into account factors such as
inflation and the hours involved in
providing a particular service and we
aim to cover costs in some cases such as
the emptying of litter and dog bins to
cover costs would mean too large an
increase at one time and as such this
will be done over several years to get
to that
point some of the fees and charges in
the report are new such as Dog Daycare
license um and others are kind of few
and far between to have a minimal impact
on the overall
income but there will be an overall
impact on the council's finances but
primarily due to the drop in planning
income that we've experienced at the
moment and this is despite a fee
increase for planning which government
permits us of
25% the fees and charges in this report
are included within the budget for the
financial year 2425 which will be
presented at next month's cabinet so
with those those minor amendments to the
report um that I've detailed um then I
would like to propose the
recommendations at 3.1 and I'd ask for a
seconder thank you
chair thank you councelor e do we have a
seconder councelor Weller thank you very
much any questions from cabinet
members councelor
winch communication of these
um out out to Residence
and Council eurn you answer that um can
I ask um
Mark
so uh I think this will be nothing's
published at the moment it will be
published as part of the budget
so
there's a sense in which it's published
today in the fact that it's in the
cabinet papers but um it won't go any
further than that until it comes to the
budget papers
yeah hopefully that answers you
councelor winch yeah any further
questions councilor wad do you have any
questions just want you pleased to hear
um Parish councils in December received
a letter from mids suffk stating that
dog and litter bins cost mids suffk £171
each year to empty and the the 2425
charge would be £69 per bin per year now
the fees and charges schedule now before
US states that for litter the charge
will be £49 representing half the cost
so in other words the cost of 98 and for
dog bins the 557 represents 42% discount
on cost so again a cost of
£98 my question is did the initial
letter with the 171 figure have cabinet
sign off before it was sent out
counc
Ean um thank you chair um it the the
letter that went out should have firstly
um we that should have been planned to
go out earlier um in terms of um
alerting Parish councils to any changes
in their charges so that they could um
incorporate any changes within their
kind of whole budget planning process um
but you might recall that um in the um
few weeks um prior to that letter going
out um we had significant flooding in
this district and the team um that was
working on that was heavily involved in
the flooding response um as were um many
members of cabinets so unfortunately
that slipped through the net in terms of
um that approach there um we have since
then um communicated that um you know we
do not wish to um put up the um fees and
charges for l little bins and dog bins
to the full extent of cost recovery and
the team um are doing some work on what
that um should be going forward to
ensure that the figures that we've got
are accurate thank you
chair thank you very much hope that
answers the
question uh any further questions now if
not we can open this item Up For
Debate anyone to contribute to the
debate councelor winch yeah I mean I
think there's a general principle in
these fees and charges and that is we
need to move the fees in line with the
costs given the state of local
government Finance otherwise it just
creates much bigger problems further
down the line but there is a balance
here and you can't put things up too
quickly because that's not reasonable
and I think this is the set of charges
has got that balance
right thank you thank you very much any
further contributions to the
debate so in terms of the uh the the dog
and litter beIN I mean I think all of us
experienced some consternation at Parish
councils when that letter came out uh I
think we were able to clarify it fairly
quickly
um the cost of emptying a dog bin or a
litter bin is essentially the same but I
think it's important that we maintain a
slight dis price disparity otherwise uh
there's the risk of Parish councils
treating every bin as a as a as a dog
bin um and I think that has some public
health
concerns um so
um I think we've we we' come to a
reasonable compromise
um but realizing that we need to move
towards full cost recovery over
time so if there's no further
contributions to the debate I will uh
just read the recommendation 3.1 that
the proposed fees and charges for 24 25
as shown in appendix a be approved I
want to ask the governance officer to
conduct the
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now in
progress
thank you members that's five votes for
that's
unanimous thank you very
much so we now move on to item 12 on the
agenda this is paper MCA stroke 23
stroke 40 the Stow Market health
education and Leisure
facilities uh project and we have a
number of officers here and uh external
Consultants too uh fion DML who's the
director for economic growth and climate
change we have Kate parnham the
Regeneration project manager he's done a
lot of work on this project and then we
have guests Nathan Swift from Saunders
Boston Architects they're not here
they're not here okay any of the others
here just
and okay so we don't have the guests
that's fine but I will um just report
that this report contains confidential
appendices if members wish to question
and debate the appendices the meeting
will need to go into a close session
before that
debate but I'll now invite the cabinet
members member for environment culture
and well-being to introduce the report
councelor
Weller thank you chair um today cabinet
being asked to approve five
recommendations and one onward
recommendation to progress activity on
the Shelf project in Stow Market the
case for increasing sporting Provisions
well articulated in our Leisure Sport
and physical activity strategy our
Sports partners and residents have eagly
awaited movement on this project for
several years so I'm delighted to bring
this paper to Cabinet now as a trigger
for a spade to finally hit the
earth successful delivery of projects of
this proportion and complexity are
dependent on engagement by multiple
dedicated players Grant and funding
sources being fully optimized and a
strategic implementation plan being
executed the first work package includes
all pitched base facilities so that
includes lengthened and improved rugby
pitch at uh chilon fields which will
make it compliant for league matches um
a new 3G pitch uh multi-use games area
Athletics mini track active track
Cricket Nets um are uh chair will be
pleased to learn um trim Trail other
improvements to existing grass pitches
connectivity and uh car park
improvements we can commence work on
this work package now because necessary
consents and funding are either agreed
wholly or agreed pending a decision at
cabinet today and subsequently at full
Council to commit an element of mids
spend from our strategic
Reserve um there may be disappointment
that the full shelf scheme isn't being
brought to Cabinet this morning and I've
noted comments from residents especially
regarding much needed availability of
specific health and well being elements
of the project but these aren't
forgotten negotiations with relevant
partners consents and funding for later
work packages require further attention
but work to progress these is underway
and will continue in tandem with the
implementation of this first
package so finally cabinet are asked to
note work already undertaken by officers
to identify management models pending a
recommendation to adopt a preferred
model which will be brought forward for
cabinet consideration in the very near
future
so I must thank um officers across
departments for their work on all
aspects of this multifaceted project and
thank sport partners and residents for
their patience and perseverance up to
this time I propose adoption of the six
recommendations
thanks thank you councelor Willer do we
have a second uh councelor
eburn any questions from cabinet members
on this
report
if not uh councelor W do you have any
questions uh thank you chair uh yes I've
got three questions and I don't believe
the questions would need us to move into
confidential but I may be wrong in terms
of but let me um my first question is do
cabinet see
shelf as a project a set of projects or
simply an overarching master plan for
this large area of land that's my first
question the second question is what
what is the situation with the Pavilion
which was a key feature of this project
based on all the earlier press releases
photos Etc are the sports clubs involved
be gifted with the capital cost of the
building but be expected to cover the
significant on ongoing Revenue costs
such as insurance maintenance and
general running costs from their very
modest resources that's my second
question and the third question is uh
Stow Market resident wrote to me
recently expressing the opinion which I
quote it's blindingly obvious that the
Hub will never happen are they right or
wrong and if they are wrong what factors
make cabinet comfortable in coming to
that
conclusion thank you for those questions
um councilor well are you happy to take
those yeah I'm happy to answer the first
two because I heard them really clearly
well we have to ask John to please just
remind me or or or to say again the
third element because I missed
that the third one said yeah a Stow
Market resident recently wrote To Me me
expressing the opinion and I quote it's
blindingly obvious that the health Hub
will never happen my question is are
they right or wrong and if they are
wrong what factors make cabinet
comfortable in coming to that conclusion
yeah thanks for that um councelor wad so
so so to come to I'll come to that point
first since you've raised it just there
um the the health Hub um and in fact I
can answer that in respect of the um
Pavilion as well would for part of um a
future work package so the so in
answering all three together both the
health Hub as you've chosen to call it
or as the resident's chosen to call it
um is will be a feature of a a a future
work package um the um Pavilion would be
another feature of another work package
to follow so what we're doing is in
answering the third element of your
question uh the overarching project is
all of it um um this been split into
work packages to make it deliverable and
and for a scheme of this size that's
absolutely uh consistent with how such a
scheme would be delivered because it
involves negotiations and partnership
working with several different different
partners um uh which involve sometimes
sensitive negotiations um and what we're
keen to do is start what we can start
now as I outlined in my introduction
because we're one in a position to
because we've got necessary consents and
grants lined up to do so and um and keep
our eye on the board with relation to
the other work packages to bring those
online as and when elements of them fall
into place to be able to deliver them
to hope that answers the questions coun
wad I think in terms of the Pavilion I
think perhaps we defer that question
till when that package comes next to
cab so no further questions we can open
up this item for
debate any cabinet members wish to make
a contribution to the debate Council
Stringer um yeah just like to say um
good to see this this document coming
forward uh good to see that it has now
been
uh pulled apart not pulled apart it's
probably the wrong phrase stripped into
different work streams because in
delivering a project like this if it's
all bundled together you're going to
move at the rate of the slowest part of
the project and I think we're right to
have looked at the entirety of of the
project uh and and take apart the
elements we know we can deliver sooner
so we can get parts of that cracking
because I know there's a lot of
aspiration in the town to see
improvements uh and and it may well that
over time uh other parts of the project
may run at different rates and perhaps
you know history will will say that
parts of the project may not get
delivered as originally envisioned but
there's yeah and that will depend on
other partners other funding being able
to be brought to the table as well uh so
I I think you it's good that we've now
brought this here to sort of draw a line
under what the strategy now is about
delivering all of this and if it has to
be delivered in in in three strands four
strands five strands doesn't matter
what's important is that we actually
deliver on what we can deliver on so
wholeheartedly support the report and
thank you to everyone in involved in
getting this fun thank you ch
thank you cast Str cast
abber thank you chair I'm I'm really
pleased to see this first part of this
project come forward um impr improved
Sports provision is desperately needed
and um so I'm very glad that we can you
know start um achieving that and getting
kind of something done this F this year
in
2024 and I think it's really important
that we continue the work with the stone
markit Town Council and all the sporting
bodies um that have got an interest here
as well as residents to make sure that
we are providing the best facilities for
them and I look forward to the the next
parts of the project as they come
forward thank you
chair thank you anyone
else okay I'll just add a few comments
from the chair then um I think this
report fits into the broad Vision we
have to improve the sporting and
well-being facilities in Stow market and
in fact across the district um this is
in a sense a legacy project that we
inherited from the previous
administration but we see absolutely the
uh the Merit in it and we want to move
it forward and we are um committed to it
um it's good that we're able to progress
this first work package and get work
underway this year I know that's
something that the town uh the town
count Council and residents of Stone
Market are very very keen to see but
it's really important that we move
forward uh in a financially sustainable
way making sure that we've got the
funding in place and as Council wad has
said that we don't leave um a kind of
Burden around the necks of the sports
club but going forward that we have a
sustainable model for um for that to
continue um with um without it falling
over in the future so I'm very pleased
that we're bringing this forward the um
the application will come to planning
committee uh and we hope that that is um
approved so that we can move forward
very quickly and see um Spades in the
ground in due course um again I echo my
colleagues thanks to the officers for
all the hard work that's gone in I know
it's been a long process getting to this
this point but um we're very grateful
for all that you've done and I will
certainly be voting for The for this I
would better just read the
recommendations I don't think there's
any need for us to to go
into into restricted session so
hopefully we can just carry on and do
this got quite a number of
recommendations to read out 3.1 the
cabinet endorsed the full business case
for work package one in respect of the
Stow Market health education and Leisure
facilities as attached in appendix a 3.2
the cabinet approved the full delivery
of this element of the project as
outlined in the full business case which
will include pitch and landbased
elements of the overall master plan
3.3 that cabinet if minded to approve
recommendation 3.2 improve the
recommended funding strategy detailed in
appendix b as the cabinet's preferred
method of delivering the project subject
to the securing of all internal and
external funding outlined in the
recommended funding
strategy
3.4 the cabinet delegate its Authority
for completion of all necessary matters
and agreements pursuant to the approval
of recommendation
3.3 including any land legals and
transactions required to facilitate work
package one to the council's director
for economic growth and climate change
and
section1 officer stroke director for
corporate resources in consultation with
the cabinet member for environment
culture and
well-being 3.5 that cabinet notes work
carried out to date on a sustainable
management model for The Wider Stow
Market health education Leisure
facilities as outlined in appendix a but
agree that a further recommendation on
the preferred model will be brought back
to cabinet for consideration later in
the year and then we have an onward
recommendation to council 3.6 that
Council approve the addition of this
project to the capital program as
outlined in the recommended funding
strategy specifically the council's
commitment of £450,000 from the
council's Strategic Reserve towards the
total cost of delivery of work package
one for I will now ask the governor's
officer to conduct the
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now in
progress
thank you members uh that's five votes
for chair that's
unanimous thank you very
much that is
passed so in conclusion just to mention
that the next meeting of the cabinet is
scheduled for Tuesday the 6th of
February at 9:30 a.m. do we know the
venue yet it's here sir it will be here
again okay and I declare the meeting
closed